- It is an absolute dream
to be here in LA this week,
kicking off our premiere week.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you for being with us.
We didn't have the privilege
of launching our show in
Season 1 with an audience.
And I just wanna tell you
that you could never be more appreciated
and not just because we
didn't have the privilege
in Season 1,
but I don't think of
you guys as an audience.
I think of you guys as guests on the show.
Hopefully, when you watch this
episode, you'll see yourself.
Hopefully, when you watch this episode,
you'll feel yourself
because your energy, your
presence, and your time,
and choosing to spend it here
is gonna affect the show.
So please, everything that's positive,
take it with you,
we needed out there in the world.
And thank you for spending
your time with us today.
You could choose to spend it anywhere,
but you chose to be here, so thank you.
And...
(audience claps)
...it means a lot to us.
I hope that you have a
fantastic rest of your day,
and we hope to see you again real soon.
Take this with you.
(audience claps)
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)